[Music]
guess who's gonna who now not just in
text but on his show responded to Dana
White
oh boy oh yeah and he's a tough boy like
somebody said in the comments never has
somebody tried to be crystalia so hard
here you go
no you you bit of a rabble Rouser what
happened
well hey hold on let me ask them what
happened yeah read any new site well
what's the joke
also yeah are you doing he's doing the
Will Sasso thing yeah he's an idiot he
steals things all the time and I don't
think he does it on purpose I think he's
like a baby he just picks up his
surroundings because that's like the
Will Sasso because that's the will
assassin was like you keep [ __ ] with
me man and you're gonna get [ __ ]
taken down and he's yeah yeah what are
you gonna do use some of that
oxen you've been doing
that's like a Will Sasso pit
hmm I got a lot of hey what happened I
got blasted apparently your your boy
provides a bow
stirring them why are they laughing
maybe I missed the setup because he's
doing a funny voice oh well his
vocabulary's hello what did you do what
did you do hey like oh that's supposed
to be Dana White that he's saying that's
how Dana White talks okay that's the
joke I got it um you know what I'm doing
my night what are you doing I'm on I'm
about to is shopping friend I'm about it
he's about it that's right Minnesota so
it'll be cool yeah I'm there with Dalia
air Griffin he's done too quiet brags
but just tell me I'm not so we're all
chilling and then my brother's like ah
[ __ ] Dana called you a [ __ ] idiot and
I'm like
he's very to the point well he's also
right his vocabulary I don't like Dana
White either by the way so it's not like
I but people think I'm just defending
Dana I don't give a [ __ ] about Dana
White I just think it's funny that
Brendan when he sent that Instagram post
was talking about himself too what did
you do what did you do hey like his
vocabulary dude does it come with
[ __ ] seltzers what are you doing dude
how [ __ ] dare you talk about the way
anybody else talks Brendan yeah he has
no self-awareness this is ridiculous
comedy Bruce Spring spring George
Carlton girl what else do you need bro
you [ __ ] talk like somebody took a
[ __ ] Scrabble board and threw it in a
dryer
you are the dumbest person I've ever
seen
and even you criticizing how people talk
is like me telling somebody at a bar I
think maybe you've had enough it's it's
it's you know what I mean like hey you
need to cool it but yeah
you're such a broke are you rushing for
six months no before you tell the story
I don't I purposely stayed ignorant I
just got a bunch of questions
so that went viral and then I went oh oh
and then
I didn't think it was much you know on
the schaab show every Monday I get on
there and be stop plugging your stupid
show stupid nobody cares about the
things he's floundering he [ __ ] lost
his biggest Money Maker I'm looking at
your thick Boy network homie you ain't
doing that well because now he's trying
to trying to thread everything together
as best he can it's just this look I
don't care if two dudes are fighting but
this is just making fun of somebody's
vocabulary you're off to a bad start bro
you know you don't you're not a you
don't speak too good any fights over 15
fights and you'll see I've been in those
um the way and so when he goes oh Marlon
Wayans when he goes oh it was uh so much
chaos and Mayhem we have to shut down
the weigh-ins I watch I went Iration huh
how about the footage is your tongue
bigger than usual today Brendan and he
lit day goes by nothing another day goes
by nothing after the fights I'm like
they're gonna release some of it nothing
they release one like half-assed video
but it was weak so yeah so then so I was
like let's just go through the math here
okay I don't want you to do any math
please don't do math please don't do
math Brendan Brandon you're so stupid
it's crazy right
thank you Brian I agree with you right
what are you saying Brian I think
Brian's just like had a realization that
like he's like no I mean like in all the
time I've known you what are you say
you're saying I don't it just hit me I
don't know what you're saying at any
time
look I've always said this Brian Callan
can be and has been very funny
I'm not saying the Brian Collins I don't
think Brandon's ever been funny but
um it's it's this false like
dude You Gotta Be You Gotta call him out
for like just talking about himself
let's maybe that's what I'm saying or
are you just asking questions I'm asking
questions so but here's my question
there's 26 fighters on the card on that
particular card each fighter gets
minimum two cornermen so let's say two
to three if you have the main event can
have five right and there's basically
two main events so that's if they both
have a calculator so five times four do
you know so so you know so you have 20
there so 78 total but let's say you know
the main event so but and then you get
to it security let's just round it down
to a nice number like a hundred what
those weigh-ins guys are bored as [ __ ]
everybody's on their phone to entertain
them and they're getting their mind off
the fight everybody's on their phone so
if there was Mayhem what would happen no
I you just put it in here quotes
you're already saying that no no I'm
just saying no Mayhem so if there was
Mayhem for the biggest UFC he's this
never happened before because oh there's
never been drama in the UFC it sounds
like when a kid is saying something to
his parents like excited so then so then
I walked up to the guy and then the guy
Mom Mom are you listening mom well mom
so that I I walked up I walked up to the
guy and then Dana and then Mom Mom
you're not even paying it Mom forget it
see also there's no there's there's no
also longer shorts please I don't want
to see your dick bro
camera crew at all all then you're
saying nobody has cameras on their phone
oh it's so weird man so so to man I mean
when he said that all I said is like I'm
not a big conspiracy guy if you want to
talk about JFK JFK Jr
I'm your huckleby you want he's huckle B
did he just say huckle B oh my God he's
not Huckleberry not Huckleberry he said
huckle B he said huckle Bees No that's
right you want to go with me bro I'm
your Michael B what's up
I'll be your Sarah Huckabee Sanders
homie you want to go that [ __ ] hard
I'm so excited
we got a new shop is and we got a new
shopism I'm your hookup I'm your Mike
Huckabee like you said I love it I'm
your Mike Huckabee bro
oh he's the dumbest person who's ever
lived he really is the stupidest human
being
holy [ __ ] JFK JFK Jr
ready you gotta here I need that again
you ready
I'm your huckleby huckleby hold on I'm
your husband
not Huckleberry I'm your huckleby I'm
your huckleby
maybe he was saying I'm your huckle be e
you know what I mean like calling
somebody B
that that
he's my that might be my favorite
Brendan shavism I'll copy out of all of
them Huckleberry is my absolute favorite
one
so I'm so happy Sage [ __ ] Brandon
Schaub I may come and offered he can't
refute probably
I'm gonna make him an offer he can't
refute yes
bro let me tell you something man you
need someone to party with I'm your
huckleby I'm your huckleberry
can I get a shirt please can we get we
need new shirts some new ROTC stuff on
Teespring what do you say I'm your uncle
I'm your huckle B yes
JFK JFK Jr one more time we're here we
share one more time right just till we
get out of our system here I'm your
huckleby you want to talk about Charles
Manson why didn't he correct him I would
have corrected you you and I if either
one of us did that by mistake because
he's tired of doing it we would jump
down each other's Throne be like huckle
pee you mean Huckleberry I can just
watch Brian's face when he says it okay
okay good call good call let's keep an
eye on Brian's face just just watch
Brian's face okay I got it and it's like
I'm not a big conspiracy guy if you want
to talk about JFK JFK Jr I'm your
huckleby you want to talk about
yeah
yeah
you're right Marsh I think he's so tired
of doing it that he's like because it's
not gonna stick no you know what I mean
Charles Manson I read chaos I'm your
huckle B he said it twice he said it
twice he said it twice he said it twice
he said it twice he said it twice he
said it no come back come back here
we're not done
well she just thinks that's how it is he
just thinks that's that's the word he
thinks that's the word he said it twice
which means it wasn't another like I
have a speech impediment it was a I'm an
idiot
I'm your huckleby
outside that I don't entertain the
lizard people entertain Flat Earth I
don't entertain a lot of this [ __ ] so
someone's gonna re-cut that scene from
the movie right
I'm your huckleby thank you but when it
comes to that I just have some questions
you just ask them questions and I'm a
[ __ ] dummy
yes
you asking questions this is what makes
you dumb it's everything else Johnny
bingo
it's Ringo okay yeah
no asking questions Brendan trying to
speak Latin yeah exactly you're you're
dumb as [ __ ] and you're asking questions
look bro I hear you heard you but I'm
your huckleby okay
yeah he read that then it was it was in
the book Tom sawyan
well here's the thing here's the thing
you can't keep doing this stupid voice I
call another grown man a [ __ ] dummy
at a press conference you're a [ __ ]
dummy
and if I ever met a press conference
I'll make sure I say it okay I promise
and I'm just gonna lay back and be chill
because there's other things it's pretty
funny well it's funny but also nothing
about those it's there's something about
when you call somebody what you call
somebody when you were in middle school
that cracks me up like just going you're
a dumb you know what's funny about it oh
Brian even Brian's kind of not trying to
you see what it's at he's not even yeah
because Brian still wants to be able to
go to UFC things your point what is he
has 400 million dollars in the bank and
then still cause people [ __ ] Dana
gets emotional Dana's an emotional guy
right yeah and Brian knows what that's
like
sure we can you know try to help them as
much as we can and I get it my thing is
that you know once why don't they print
all this stuff I say good about it
when's the last thing well about him
um sure
links
thank you
is that Huckleberry Hound
yes okay why is this always Brendan
I [ __ ] love lean I'm your huckleby I
love it
uh why is Brendan always doing this
thing where it's like like he can be not
nice but other people can't be not nice
and then he always wants to be like what
about all the nice things I said you
basically like accused Dana White of
fraud
well on top of that he's saying he's
saying that you just can't do that you
know what else you can't do you you
can't accuse Bobby Lee of running an
intricate hacking Syndicate that was
trying to have your family killed
remember that like that's what I'm
saying is there's so many things that
he's done this is like a pattern of
behavior but even this time with UFC
it's like it's like he's saying why
don't you show you all the nice things I
say about you it's like okay but here's
the thing right if I saw you every day
and every day I had a compliment like
hey nice shirt hey I like that hat
then one day I just go on my show and I
go look I think Royce is committing
crimes and fraud and I think that he's a
criminal and needs to go to prison
um and then you go yo what the [ __ ] what
are you a [ __ ] idiot and I go oh what
I can't criticize you what about all
times I said you had a nice shirt and
you're like you went on the air and
accused me of crimes like that's I mean
I'm gonna take exception with that I
mean thank you it is a nice shirt but
you said I basically committed I
defrauded my millions of pay-per-view
customers Ray wombat five dollars howdy
friends yeah that's a good point and um
this is another weird one that Brendan
keeps doing because Brandon now this is
you know this this is an effect again
Brandon's friends with Joe Joe still
does the fight commentary so now it's
another weird thing and how much is Joe
gonna put up the how many fires is
Brendan gonna start that Joe has to keep
putting up with I know you don't think
Dana's not gonna bring this up to Joe
I'm dude of course he is like not in any
like shitty way and then and there's
your [ __ ] idiot friend doing that
[ __ ] [ __ ] and then Joe's gonna say
I'll talk to him
he's still do the I know man I'll talk
to him I'll talk to him
heard me say something bad about him you
go ahead so when he stuck up for our
Buddy Joe Rogan I went you know what our
Buddy Joe Rogan our Buddy Joe Rogan and
go ahead and play the [ __ ] tape back
for all the people that are both I went
you know what because what he did for
Rogan's not my story to tell I've never
told the story but I'm gonna quit being
so hard on Dana I don't know how the
company goes you know so I'm gonna quit
nitpicking everything so you were really
significant no but but he was super
nitpicky who he missed it he admit it
and then he [ __ ] that's it you have
to admire your mother-in-law and then
the pico de gallo just fly right off
it's like right off the car
you're too sting they're stinky oh
you've been you've been Fair because
you've said a lot of times you said I
don't know what it's like to run the UFC
so for me to criticize Dana yeah that's
insane I mean I can criticize right now
yeah I mean I could do it but still use
that brain surgery but also
what hold on guys what's not brain
surgery no no no yes yes that's what he
listens becoming a becoming a
billionaire it's not brainstorm listen
listen quit nitpicking everything no
you've been you've been Fair because
you've said a lot of times you said I
don't know what it's like to run the UFC
so for me to criticize Dana yeah that's
insane I mean I can criticize right now
I could do it
I could do it you could run a billion
dollar company you can't you can't run
your own YouTube channel successfully
yeah you the only thing you can the only
thing you've ran lately is you ran Theo
Vaughn off your [ __ ] show and you and
you left your car running in the [ __ ]
Comedy Store parking lot well you got
ahead I mean so look stop I'm not
defending Dana but to pretend that you
could have this just in Brendan sharp
thinks he could run the US I could do it
I just don't want to
because my back
yeah I mean I can do it but still use
that brain surgery but also he's the guy
one negative thing but yeah can I say
something there there are more brain
surgeons
on the planet than there are
billionaires
yeah that's right that's a really good
point so one would I think would be
harder right yeah he's saying negative
it sounds to me like so let me get what
you're saying and I said I said I went
on the paint but also he went hard in
the paint all right he's your huckleby
let me get what you're saying let me
just stop you and say you are hey merge
later this weekend do you want to get
some dollar readers at hucklebees
[Music]
he's a rattlesnake
a rabble Rouser I'm a rabble Rouser
you're a rabbit
yeah I'm all bunched up
now here's the thing is this funny to
people you're you're let's see the ratio
654 up 3K down
thank you is that bad thank you Chrome
plug-in
no and again dislikes matter more now
Because unless you go out of your way
you don't see them you know
it's like you're saying this
I'll I'll answer back but it sounds like
you're saying this it sounds like you're
saying that Kevin Holland did not
Spartan Kick
comes out to my in the chest yeah he
[ __ ] up right because it's Hamza
Spartan Kick yes I'm sorry I'm sorry
okay huckleby you're saying that there
wasn't a toss from him if I'm in my 400
million dollars in the bank here I'm
Mickey Mouse
go ahead I'm at the press conference uh
next question a guy who I seen how he
picked so you don't uh bring up anything
controversial go oh says the person
who's completely isolated themselves
online who doesn't go on social media
anymore who literally has been pixels go
after other people and you're suing a
small time drunk YouTuber that guy
that guy you're so you're telling me the
guy the guy the guy the guy the guy in
the six inch shorts I like that he
specifically had to throw drunk in there
no but this is [ __ ] ridiculous a
small drunk YouTuber yeah I don't
understand Brennan how [ __ ] dare you
man
you you basically you
you try to Ocean's 11 Bobby Lee
go damn it he's gonna make Bobby Lee do
all the gymnastics stuff no that's
you're just [ __ ] racist you
immediately went he was gonna be the
little Asian guy didn't you
hey go low energy white minion
you're white
you're up I don't identify as white
anybody else anybody else who doesn't
subscribe to every subscribe subscribe
huckle B hey make sure to subscribe
huckle be see back for show notes
see show notes for about the details
every word I say get out of it do you
mind if I ask a question I'm so sorry I
went on a rant what's your [ __ ]
question why is he talking like this he
sounds like a [ __ ] [ __ ]
in the back what do you got
my question sir old wood face what do
you guys stop you're not funny
who lied to you who lied to you Joe
Rogan oh do you mind sir Brian Callan
and all these other guys
because they don't want to disappoint
Joe Rogan
got it sorry I don't like this ad
hominem insults I'm so sorry that's a
stupid question
was suggesting that maybe there wasn't a
tussle I didn't say bread and Shop that
was at the end of it he realized it was
branded shop that's not what happened
and maybe you're drumming up controversy
for
I don't know
clicks or something what now you know as
a good Journal I'll answer that question
but as a good journalist you should ask
really what exactly Brennan shop said do
your due diligence before you open up
what did you say before you open up your
fat red trap what did you
Brennan you're not for somebody who
could beat somebody up you're so not
intimidating I know that sounds crazy
and I understand that you could probably
kick me to the [ __ ] next County I
understand this that's what they
remember that's always the argument
people give us when we brag on Brendan
it's like yeah you could kick your
[ __ ] yes you can I'm like yes so
before anyone says anything Brandon can
[ __ ] kick our ass that's 100 I get it
but if you're gonna put your hands on me
for making funny verbally that's a very
unreasonable way to handle it right
Papa
what did I say papa Hey Oh I said red
fat red trap all Ice Baby
sad was I have something
questions
you can't be monetized on YouTube
see all right but the chance of that's
not good and also I get his his argument
about the commission stuff like that all
I'm saying is that some questions
because for this to work out exactly
like it did everything would have to
come in line you you take the Nate Diaz
out of the fight right and so it just so
how it works out where hamzatz find 180
pound man right and he just happened to
weigh 180 pounds and then uh wait okay
I'm sorry shut up I'm not talking about
he goes well all the marketing they put
into it they have an idea Mark the
marking they're put into it all the
marker and they printed huckleby my
theory again I'm not dying on this hill
I wish it would be somewhere though it
doesn't have to be a hill yeah it could
be a Blake it could be a mountain a
hotel a desert airplane leather chair
tan leather chair
[Music]
[Laughter]
I don't know why that got me
tape hey Siri who's arpa Dwyer
I'm I'm definitely not dying this hill
but we'll get to how I can validate
myself links it's t-shirt sized oh
well guess what man
and it's a transparent too I'm your
huckleberry and it's transparent too
that is wonderful
oh he's so dumb oh he's so stupid
thank you bestie it's very good
um
let's see where was I over here
my theory is it wasn't trending well
because the treatment of Nate Diaz a
legend of the UFC a guy who's put his
life on the line a guy who's always
fought the man wanted out of his
contract has demanded a fight for a year
now so he likes wild conspiracy theories
but you can't make it of him
because you'll sue you right I just want
to make sure that we're on the same page
here
you know what I'm talking about